In this video you're going to learn how to navigate
the Algebra 1 final exam review
We're going to be going through together 33 different question types, in total, 80 different problems
So let's get started into this video. If you want to get the most out of it
I suggest
Pausing the video, seeing if you can do the problem on your own
And then we'll go through it together and  you can see which ones you need more help on
And I've got videos going over these concepts in greater detail
on my Mario's Math Tutoring YouTube channel
so if you need help you can go there for additional resources
Let's get started into the video the first question talks about
solving an equation and this equation
you can see is negative 3
time x minus 2 minus 5 equals negative 11
so what do you think, how would you solve that problem
Well if I was going to solve it, what I would do is
I would distribute this negative 3, okay, into the parentheses
and that's going to give us negative 3x  and negative 3
times a negative two give us positive 6, right
minus 5, equals negative 11. I always like to combine
like-terms first
So that's going to be 6 minus 5, which is 1
And then what we'll want to do
is we want to get the variables on one side, numbers on the other
so we'll subtract 1 from both sides
that gives us negative 3x equals negative 12
and if I divide both sides by negative 3, you just want to get this x by itself
you can see that we get x equals 4
So the question that they were really testing you on in this particular problem
is do you know the distributive property?
And do you know how to solve
equations? So that's how you do the first one, let's
go to the second one now,
It says, solve
5x minus 2 divided by 20 equals x divided by 5
So what do you think, what would you do to solve that problem?
Well, if I was going to do it, what I would do is I would
use the cross-multiplying technique, okay
so I would multiply on the diagonals. So 5x minus 2
times 5, alright
Equals 20 times x
Okay, so are you with me so far?
So then what I would do is I would
distribute this 5 into the parentheses, that's 25x minus 10, okay? Because 5 times negative 2 is negative 10
And then what you want to do is you want to get the variables on one side and the numbers
on the opposite side
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to subtract
the 25x from both sides.
Now, a lot of students like to get the variables on the left, but it doesn't really matter
as long as you get the numbers and the variables
on opposite sides, that's the key. 20 minus 25
is negative 5x. And then we just want to get the x by itself
So the opposite of multiplying by negative 5
would be to divide by negative 5. So negative
10 divided by negative 5 is positive 2. These cancel
You're just going to get x by itself and x equals 2
Now, the nice thing about Algebra is that oftentimes you can check your answer
by taking that value, 2, putting it into the original
problem wherever you see x, simplifying, and making sure that
the left side and the right side
equal each other. That way, you know you've got it right.
Now, the question or the topic that you're tested on in this question
is working with proportions. So proportions
are a ratio equaled to a ratio. And you can use that cross multiplying technique
or that cross product technique
to solve the equation.